Philip we're hearing a lot about a
British version of the Magnitsky acts
which is the american measure how would
this work in practice well the
interesting line for me from tourism a
statement was that one about freezing
russian state assets and i think that's
the one that's got the city spooked so
that is any entity that's owned directly
by the russian state is now vulnerable
and within an hour of that statement we
had clients calling us up saying i'm
structuring a deal with a russian
company owned by the state am i exposed
right so i mean potentially anyone doing
business with those companies could face
punishments as well yeah absolutely it
could be restrictions on capital raising
or potentially the actual freezing of
assets and that's a very big potentially
difficult legal and technical thing to
do but the russian the UK government may
press ahead with that and potentially
hits the revenues of all that advisory
community in london accountants lawyers
banks PR absolutely the service sector
for russians in london is huge you know
every major law firm now has a VIP
russian desk there's a lot of money
flowing into london and that's where
russians come to raise capital unless
their stocks
so if russian assets are frozen
potentially could that money be diverted
to other financial centers
well the russian has a long claimed that
they can go to the far east they could
go to Hong Kong for IPOs they could get
money from China that's true to a
certain extent Chinese money comes with
strings
the Chinese are pressured Russia one
very good example is the power of
Siberia pipeline took ten years to
negotiate and the Chinese really got a
very good bargain and the Russians came
off very badly on that one
some people are saying though we haven't
seen any specific measures against Putin
related individuals or entities no no no
she's kept that in the back pocket I
mean she started with the easy stuff the
diplomats you Hoover up all the agents
you want to expel the royal family I'm
going to the World Cup I think in the
next couple of weeks it's going to be
quite interesting to watch what will
come next concrete measures that really
target individuals close to the regime
what's it's going to mean for the London
property market those prime properties
that have been snapped up by oligarchs
over the last week well yeah I mean you
could argue that perhaps as you know
it's not going to target every Russian
London is still seen as a refuge people
like to come here to educate their
children to keep their assets safe it's
a very liquid market it's a bit like
gold holding their London property and
it's just not just Russia
so it's Kazakhs it's a many different
you know countries come to stall that
they're wealthier about the position of
BP because BP of course owns 20% of
Rosneft Russia's biggest company it gets
a third of its revenues from there these
days
BP squarely in the sights if there's any
Russian retaliation quite yeah BP and
she'll both so both companies have had
torrid times in Russia BP with tnk in
the mid-2000s shell lost Sakhalin one
two gas prom they're stuck there it's
very profitable but they are vulnerable
so what would you be advising BP right
now
I think sit it out keep quiet make as
little comment as possible and hope that
commercial diplomacy that business
between the UK and Russia continues
unabated despite the deteriorating
political situation yes we forget I mean
London is still a prime place for
Russian companies to list here we've had
en plus of course one of the big yeah
yeah what is his producers you you have
you had some of D Lister's as well so I
think the neural scoliosis relisted
again some have left I mean we had the
Kazakh company in RC so there's been a
mixed mixed bag on that front but I
think Russians have always enjoyed
coming to the London for cultural
reasons for financial reasons because
the quality of the service sector here
and I think it'll be a big loss for them
you've obviously been involved with
Russia for most of your business career
going back a quarter of a century here
is there a danger that we with none of
us any younger is there a danger that
we're painting the Russians into a
corner with some of this stuff yeah I
think you know it's very III think
there's danger here that you put them in
the corner there's no dialogue there's
no channel of communication and bear in
mind we have an election on Sunday the
turnover was was likely to be lackluster
but now nothing unites Russians around
their leader like pressure from the West
I think if you criticize Russia though
unite around their leader and put in
Putin's popularity I guarantee will
spike following what's happened to
resource actions in some ways could be
counterproductive but what do we do then
smother them with kind very difficult
you know do sanctions work yeah I I
would argue that the oil price collapse
hurt Russia more than sanctions did you
know sanctions United the company the
country it arguably helped their
agricultural sector as well so
not a silver bullet